[Noel] This time…
Slainte. Let's go for it.
…it's Bread Week.
-Don't let him psych you out.
-It's too late.
[Noel] The bakers face
a savoury Signature…
-Feel like it's a game of chicken.
-Stick it, stick it!
…get down with doughnuts in the Technical…
-[Noel] Nice onion rings.
-They're not onion rings!
…and tackle a sweet bread Showstopper.
-[Jasmine] I'm shaking a bit.
-Please don't squash.
[Noel] Who will have reason to celebrate?
Yay! So beautiful.
[Noel] And who will end up feeling flat?
-[Aaron] It's not risen.
-Do you think Paul will notice? [laughs]
[opening theme music playing]
[indistinct chattering]
You excited? It's gonna be fun.
-I am very excited.
-Yeah.
But, erm, yes, still very nervous.
I'm really surprised I make it through
to week three, Bread.
I think the Showstopper last week
saved me.
And I'm coming back. [chuckles]
Yeah, feeling good about week three.
I think bread is my strength.
If I was to do well in any week,
it would be this week.
It's gonna be a surreal moment
having Paul Hollywood eat my bread.
[laughs] So it better be good.
Paul is a master of bread.
So, no pressure! [laughing]
Welcome back to the tent, bakers,
for Bread Week.
So, for your first challenge,
the judges would love you to bake
a delicious savoury monkey bread.
[Noel] Now, you have to make
your own monkey bread.
You can't just steal some bread
off a monkey and bake that.
The judges are looking
for a well flavoured pull-apart loaf
made with a yeasty bread dough.
Your monkey bread
needs to be visually striking
through the use
of coloured flavoured doughs,
or glazes, or coatings, or toppings.
Basically, you can go ape with this.
[Noel] You have three hours.
On your monkey marks.
-[chuckling] Get set.
-Bake!
[uplifting music playing]
I'm so nervous right now. [chuckles]
I've never made monkey bread before
until practising for this, obviously,
and now I've made loads and loads
of savoury monkey bread.
You little monkey. [giggling]
Monkey bread is a round loaf of bread
which is made up of lots
of little balls of dough.
Why is it called monkey bread?
There's got to be a reason.
The reason it's called monkey bread is
everybody pulls a little piece off.
You're like a monkey.
I'm part monkey. I'm one of those monkeys
you see in markets.
-One of the cheeky ones…
-In Indiana Jones.
…robbing everybody's stuff? [chuckles]
To impress me,
you're gonna have to come up
with something that is quite unique.
I want it to taste amazing, look amazing,
have a real depth of flavour
in your mouth.
Cheeses, I think, are gonna
really be quite strong in this challenge.
[Iain] I've got a bunch of cheese,
lovely cheese.
The final finish should really be
a celebration of colour, flavour,
lots of seeds.
It must be whole, all together,
and looking beautiful.
But above all,
it's down to the bake and proving.
Proving is gonna be the one
that makes or breaks
this particular challenge.
Get that wrong in any way,
or you underprove or underbake,
it's gonna be a problem.
-Morning, Iain.
-[Prue] Hello, Iain.
So, Iain, can you tell us all about
your monkey bread, please?
So my monkey bread is gonna be modelled
after an Irish cheese board.
-So I've got three lovely Irish cheeses.
-[Paul] Nice.
Is this your sort of week, is it, bread?
I would say
bread is the main thing that I do.
I make bread every day.
So have you practised this?
-It worked out all right?
-[Iain] Yeah.
My girlfriend actually told me
to practise it more
-'cause she wanted to eat it more.
-Oh, she was hungry?
[all laughing]
[Alison] Iain's trio of Irish cheese
will be combined with pear,
apples and blackberries,
flavours that girlfriend Dervla
has given her seal of approval.
So when did you meet this girl then?
-I love talking love.
-Oh…
First week of freshers in uni.
-Mm. The first week?
-First week.
-In the wee bar.
-Mm-hmm.
And, erm, we were both sitting down.
-We were like, "Do you wanna get a drink?"
-Hmm.
"Sweet. Let's get a drink."
I stood up.
I finished here.
Erm, she stood up, she finished there.
[both laugh]
-So she towers over you?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
And does she mind having a little man?
-No, I'm a short king.
-Yeah, man. Short king.
-She likes her short king.
-Yeah.
-Morning, Aaron.
-Good morning.
-[Alison] Hi, Aaron.
-Hello, hello, hello.
Aaron, your monkey bread.
Tell us about it.
So I'm doing a onion bread
with chilli and fennel.
Then it's rolled in Gruyère cheese,
nigella seeds and chives.
There's some yeast extract
in the dough, but…
-[chuckles]
-[Paul] I phased out then.
-[Aaron chuckles nervously]
-I was in, and then I was out.
[Noel] Aaron is putting
even more yeast extract
in the glaze for his bread
and his onion dipping sauce
in his attempt to convert Paul's palate.
He might go, "This is the greatest bread
I've ever tasted".
Well, he hates my flavour, so…
Oh, does he?
What about Prue? She likes it?
-Prue's down.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's not a bad thing
if he doesn't like something
and Prue does like it.
-She's quite strong.
-But not on Bread Week. [laughs]
Not on Bread Week, no.
[Alison] While Aaron is pinning his hopes
on a love-it or hate-it ingredient,
Jessika is taking her inspiration
from her favourite alfresco flavours.
So I've gone for picnic season
because, well,
being in the sunshine with friends,
eating delicious food,
is a delightful thing.
So it's gonna have caramelised onions,
blue cheese, figs and walnuts.
Picky bits.
[Alison] Jessika's aiming for
a texture-packed monkey bread
with crunchy walnuts, creamy blue cheese
and succulent figs.
[Paul] You've got
a lot of liquid in yours.
Don't let him psych you out.
It's too late. I'm already psyched.
-Good luck.
-[Prue] Good luck, Jessika.
Good luck. And breathe.
-[exhales]
-[Alison laughs]
I'm going for it! [laughs]
I'm just giving it a knead
to build up the gluten strands.
Hopefully make it nice and light
and fluffy and tear apart.
[Alison] Once the dough is elastic enough
to see through when stretched…
[Jasmine] That's really good.
You can see the light through it.
You actually really can.
…it's ready for its first prove.
[Aaron] Put it in the proving drawer
for about 40 minutes.
In practice, it's risen quite fast.
So while that's proving,
I'm gonna prep all my ingredients.
I love using herbs.
Anything I can get herbs into, I put in.
-Morning, Jasmine.
-Morning.
-Hello, Jasmine.
-Hi. How are you?
Jasmine, tell us about your monkey bread.
[Jasmine] So, I'm gonna do
two different fillings.
I'm gonna have olives and rosemary in one,
and then 'nduja and basil in the other.
[Noel] Jasmine's spicy sausage
and basil filling
will be rolled into swirls
and paired with dough balls
filled with Kalamata olives and rosemary.
You ever tried olive and coriander?
No. Should I?
Very Cypriot Greek, yeah.
-It sounds like a great bread.
-Oh, it's classic.
-Should have done that.
-Yeah, you should've done.
Now you're freaking me out. Ah!
-[laughs] He just stares.
-[Alison] Scary, innit?
I'll go and get the coriander right now.
Thanks.
[Noel] While Jasmine is sticking to
tried and tested Mediterranean flavours…
I'm not changing my recipe.
I'm just gonna do what I know.
…Pui Man is going
for a more exotic ingredient.
Got to have a bit of morning glory.
-[Alison] What's morning glory?
-[Pui Man] It's a Chinese vegetable.
-It's a bit limp.
-[chuckles] Yeah.
[all laughing]
-Stop that!
-What?
[Alison] Pui Man hopes her red bean curd
and Asian pesto dough balls
will make the judges stand to attention.
And she's adding
Chinese five-spice to her milk bread.
I like milk bread.
You like milk bread?
I hope you like it too.
It's not in your recipe book.
-[laughs]
-[Pui Man] So…
-[Alison] Why not, Paul?
-It is.
Oh, It is? Oh, sorry.
[all laughing]
It sounds fascinating.
Can't wait to try this.
-Good luck. Thank you.
-Thank you.
[breathes deeply]
[Noel] As well as perfect bread…
Proving quite nicely.
It's coming. It's coming!
…the judges are expecting flavours
that pack a punch.
Bacon! It's so delicious!
[laughing] Oh, my God!
So today is…
We're calling it a French dégustation
because it sounds fancy. I know.
But really, it's just some
very simple French flavours.
Croque monsieur inside one.
Then we've got a French onion soup
inside another,
and then we've got steak and peppercorns
in the final one.
[Noel] Tom will be aiming
to reduce his three fillings down
and thicken with cornflour
to avoid any leakage
in his French cuisine-inspired
monkey bread.
So that is the hard part
of this challenge, is getting the flavour
without getting
too much moisture in there.
[Noel] Tom might be
flying the flag for France,
but Nadia is sticking
to her Italian roots.
[Paul] Nadia. Good morning.
-[Nadia] Morning.
-Morning.
Right, Nadia,
tell us all about your monkey bread.
We are going for 'nduja cream,
from Calabria, where my dad is from.
[Alison] Lovely.
[Nadia] Sundried tomato and black olive.
And I have foraged some wild garlic
from by mine.
You nicked that from a field in Aigburth.
Yeah, on Otterspool, right by mine.
-Yeah, I know where it is.
-[all laughing]
[Alison] Nadia's Liverpudlian
wild garlic pesto
will top her monkey bread,
which will be filled with all the flavours
of her family's hometown in Italy.
[Nadia] My dad being Italian,
pesto is just like a family favourite.
I love loads of garlic in mine.
We are a garlic family.
We always stink of garlic.
This is my pesto.
Can't go wrong with pesto, can you?
[chuckles]
Italian food is one of those things
that I really enjoy cooking.
So I'm trying to use some of the flavours
that we'll typically use at home in this
because I know that I can make them
and that they work.
It's just making sure
that they come through
strong enough in the bread.
[Noel] Toby's ode to Italy will be
a Parmesan-topped monkey bread
with porcini mushroom-flavoured
dough balls
and knots filled with his tried and tested
green pesto and red pesto.
I've never actually made
a red pesto before, so, you know…
I just love doing things in here
for the first time.
Really stressing myself out unnecessarily.
It's what I'm all about.
-Nataliia, good morning.
-Hello.
-Hello, Nataliia.
-Morning.
Right, Nataliia,
tell us all about your monkey bread.
So I'm gonna make
my family Ukrainian monkey bread.
[Paul] Mm-hmm.
And I put inside bacon filling,
cheesy balls. [chuckles]
[Prue] Okay.
[laughing] So we'll see
what's gonna happen.
[Alison] Made from an enriched dough
and stuffed with cheese, bacon and onions,
Nataliia's flavours are a nod
to the big Ukrainian tear-and-share loaves
she enjoys eating with her family.
-You make bread a lot?
-Yeah. At home.
-You do. Okay.
-Yeah, I do.
Every Sunday we're making a big bread,
and it reminds us
like this past time in Ukraine
when it was so calm and quiet and lovely.
So, yeah.
Okay. So, yeah,
there's quite a lot of emotion
in your bread, and love in your bread.
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, absolutely.
-That's what baking is all about.
-Yeah.
-Hiya, Lesley.
-Hello, good morning.
Hello, Lesley.
-Lesley, your monkey bread.
-Yes.
What are you up to?
So I'm making a Stilton,
pear and walnut monkey bread.
I like the sound of this flavour.
Yeah, sounds beautiful.
Yeah, I hope I can pull it off.
[Noel] Covered in a variety of seeds,
Lesley's hoping to balance out
the flavours of her walnut, Stilton
and pear monkey bread.
So I'm gonna chop the pears up,
mix it in with the Stilton.
How much Stilton?
-I think it's about 120 grammes.
-120 grammes?
-Yeah.
-Not a lot.
Do you think it should be more?
[Prue laughs]
My bread. Oh, look good.
[Noel] Once their dough
has doubled in size…
Yeah, it is looking quite good actually.
…the bakers can start to fill and shape
their dough balls.
So now I'm going to spread it out.
This feels really good.
This is gonna be the olive one.
[Noel] No matter how they choose
to incorporate their fillings…
Doing it almost like a dumpling.
Wrap everything over so that you get
sort of an even distribution.
…they need to ensure their monkey bread
is bursting with flavour.
[Lesley] About 160 grammes of Stilton
going in now. Lots of Stilton.
I think it's a big bite
of cheese here. [laughs]
You love watching Paul knead bread,
apparently. Is that true?
Yes, how do you know that?
[both laughing]
It's just a rumour
that's been circulating.
Oh, my God.
That is very embarrassing, you know?
What is it about Paul kneading bread
that you like?
-He's very sexy.
-He's so handsome. Yeah, very sexy.
[both laugh]
[Noel] With his blue eyes of a husky
and his sausagey fingers.
[both laughing]
[Alison] The bakers must work quickly…
Okay, I need to really hurry.
…as the dough needs time
for a second prove before it can be baked.
If you don't prove it enough,
it'll be dense and stodgy.
So it's quite important
to get the second prove right.
I'm not panicking. Staying cool,
staying calm, staying collected.
Okay, gonna put that in.
Gonna cover that up.
Put that in a warm little proving drawer.
So I've just popped it in
for the second prove.
I'm gonna give it 40 minutes.
[in sing-song voice] Beautiful.
I'm gonna leave it to prove
for as long as physically possible.
It needs 30 minutes to bake.
So the moment it gets to 30 minutes… in.
[Alison] But two of the bakers…
Crack on, crack on. Quick, quick, quick.
…have fallen behind.
Am I the only one
that's still doing my balls?
No.
Pui Man the same as you, so it's okay.
I'm very nervous about the time.
The time is my enemy.
Bakers, you've got one hour left.
[Noel] With the monkey breads
needing around 30 minutes in the oven,
the race is on to get them proved.
You've got to put them in the oven soon,
haven't you?
Yeah, very soon.
Would you prove them more at home
if you were at home?
Yeah, well, I've put the prover on
a little bit higher than I would normally
because I was running out of time.
-Could be too high.
-Could be too much, yeah.
It's one of them.
It's like, you've got to know it.
-It's a dangerous game.
-Dangerous game.
-You like the risk, though, yeah?
-I like the risk. I'm a risky gal.
[chuckles] Good luck.
[Aaron] Mine's definitely not proved.
[Toby] It is not proved yet.
[sighs]
They look better than when I was at home.
Look rising up quicker.
So, hopefully, we'll be on time.
Something is gonna
have to be sacrificed, unfortunately.
It's gonna be this prove
because I know that underproved
is definitely not as bad as underbaked.
Underbaked is bad.
Feel like it's a game of chicken,
to be honest.
I feel like you need to push it
as long as you can.
[laughing] But you run the risk
of not finishing on time.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Slainte. Let's go for it.
It has to go in.
I have no more time to wait.
[Aaron] It's just going straight in.
We'll see what happens.
[Alison] If the bakers have prepared
their dough sufficiently…
[Nadia] Oh, I'm really hoping
my balls bake.
…then they can expect their bread to rise
as soon as it hits the oven.
[Iain] I think we should be okay.
-See.
-[whistles]
[Nataliia] Like a big bun. Like a crazy…
-♪ Da-da-da-da ♪
It's actually rising, which is amazing.
So, hopefully, it's not underproved.
-What's going on?
-My bread's not risen.
Are you actually joking?
[Aaron] There's literally no lift,
no rise, nothing.
Do you think Paul will notice? [laughs]
-I feel like he won't.
-I mean…
Aw, babes.
I'm gonna take these out the oven
in about five, six minutes.
Let it cool down.
[exhales] It's all a bit stressful.
[Alison] Okay, I've got
a magic trick for you, Jaz.
-See, lovely tea towel.
-Yeah. Mm-hmm.
-Ooh.
-[laughs]
[Jasmine] Wait, I wanna try.
-Ooh.
-Do it on Noel, do it on Noel.
I'm here.
-You ready?
-Watch this, Noel.
Ooh. Ooh.
-[laughs]
-[Alison] Do you know the trick?
Let me show you this trick,
but with one alteration.
[Alison] Right.
[all laughing]
[baaing]
Bakers, you've got five minutes left.
It's ready!
[laughing]
[Noel] Once baked, the monkey breads
need to be demoulded carefully…
[Nadia] Whoa, I'm scared.
…to prevent the balls from falling apart.
-[Toby] Oh, careful.
-[Nadia] Am I coming?
Partially. Might be worth
flipping it back over
and just trying to dislodge
a few bits, maybe.
Oh, I can't believe I did that.
[Jasmine exhales]
[tense music playing]
[Aaron] Flat as a pancake.
[Jessika] This is a mess.
[Nadia] Ooh.
So now… Oh, some of it's still in there!
-Bakers, you have one minute left.
-One minute.
Oh, God.
[gasps] Stick it, stick it,
stick it, stick it!
Just panicking. Absolutely panicking.
We brush with a little bit of oil.
This is wild garlic pesto.
Cheese hides a multitude of sins.
Maybe not these sins, but… [laughs]
Done.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away
from your beautiful monkey breads.
Looks okay,
but I don't want to be thinking
this is gonna be amazing
and then get absolutely
torn apart by Paul.
[Nadia] The whole point of it
is they're supposed to stick together.
Can't believe
I'm gonna go home on Bread Week.
-You're not going home on Bread Week.
-I'm going home on Bread Week. It's awful!
[suspenseful music playing]
[Noel] The bakers' monkey breads
will now be judged by Prue and Paul.
-Hiya.
-Hello.
Hi, Iain.
[suspenseful music playing]
I love the set-up. I think
the bake looks great, nice strong colour.
You can see the individual balls as well.
I think it looks great.
-Thank you.
-I'm gonna just take a little wedge.
So, we have blue cheese
and it has pear and fennel.
For the next one, we have a harder cheese,
and it has apple and caramelised onion.
And then for the last one,
we have a Brie-style
with blackberry and rosemary.
I love the flavour.
It's that wonderful sharpness
from the blackberries.
I mean, it's just really rich cheese.
[Paul] Superb. Love the flavours.
I was getting some… was it nuts in there?
Nuts, rolled in, er, walnuts.
It worked really well with the pear
and the blue cheese together.
I think you've ended up
with something that's quite delicious.
Thanks very much.
[gentle music playing]
[Prue] I think it looks really appetising.
It's interesting
that you've used so many seeds.
That's enough seeds.
Like the bottom of a birdcage, innit?
[Prue laughs]
So, I have got a pear, Stilton
and walnut monkey bread.
It's really nicely baked,
so that the outside is really crispy.
[Paul] I really like
the flavour of the pear.
-Stilton is lacking.
-Okay.
You needed
a little bit more Stilton in there.
-Good job, though. It tastes great.
-Thank you.
-Very delicious.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] Love the look of it. Quite quaint.
So, these ones are the French onion soup.
These ones are the steak.
And these ones are the croque monsieur.
That's delicious.
It's quite sweet because there's onion.
Flavours are great.
Punchy, strong, spot on.
That croque monsieur,
I spent two years in Paris as a student.
-I lived on croque monsieur.
-[Paul] Yeah.
And it tastes like it.
Dough needs lightening up a little bit.
It's a bit heavy.
-I think it's decent, though.
-Thank you so much, guys.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] The balls are quite big,
which makes it more tear-and-share
-than monkey bread.
-Yeah.
Nevertheless, it looks good,
and it looks well baked as well.
Thank you. Flavour, it's bacon and onions,
cheese and parsley, and a bit of pesto.
It's quite sweet, actually.
-Yeah.
-It's a bit oversweet.
You need to celebrate the savoury
and not the sweet.
A bit stodgy as well.
It's a little doughy,
but if you get a bit towards the edge,
it's absolute perfection.
-Thank you so much.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] I think it looks great.
One thing I do like
is the fact that it does fall apart.
So there's chutney, blue cheese,
fig and thyme.
Love the flavours.
Love the combination of flavours.
You're adding not just flavours,
but textures as well.
Okay.
-I think you've done a very good job.
-[Prue] So do I. Well done.
-[Paul] Well done, Jessika.
-Thank you.
-[Paul] I think it looks rough and ready.
-[Nadia] Okay.
[Paul] Because it's broken up a lot.
[Nadia] It's all the flavours of Calabria.
Sundried tomatoes, black olive.
We've got the 'nduja,
and I've made it into a cream
with mascarpone.
I've filled the other balls with pesto.
[Paul] It's really tight, isn't it?
It should be
a little bit more open than that.
-Okay.
-But the flavours, though.
I can't argue with the flavours.
The flavours are amazing.
I quite like that.
I mean, I love a milk loaf
because it's a little bit cakey.
-I think it's really delicious.
-Thank you, Prue.
-[Paul] Yeah, well done. Thank you.
-Thank you.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] An impressive-looking thing.
I like the fact that you've got
all the little balls you can see,
but they are slightly misshaped,
but that's fine.
Let's have a look, shall we?
Take a slice out of this.
[Toby] So this is
an Italian flavour-inspired bread.
So we have porcini mushroom and garlic,
and then red pesto and green pesto knots.
The mushroom one is so intense.
-It's really good. Deep flavour.
-[Toby] Oh, good.
[Paul] I think the pesto one's a bit weak.
The bake on it is all right.
I think proving is a little bit shy
and needed longer.
Overall, it's not bad.
I think your flavour's just lacking.
I'm a little more enthusiastic.
I think it tastes absolutely delicious.
That's good to hear. Thanks.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] Love the look of this.
Very neat. The balls are all there.
You can see everything. Clever.
-Well, it looks very attractive.
-[Paul] It does.
Yeah, let's have a quick look.
So, my monkey bread, I have two flavours.
There's an olive and rosemary one,
and then an 'nduja and basil.
[inhales]
Not getting the rosemary with the olive.
I'd like to see more olive.
Even then, I would have always
had coriander with an olive.
It's absolutely delicious.
It's just that if I didn't know
there were olives in there,
I wouldn't necessarily know there was.
But if you sat down with some friends
and that.
-Glass of wine. Perfect.
-Agreed, yeah.
-Thank you, Jasmine.
-Thank you.
Just need some wine and some friends.
-[laughs]
-And coriander.
[laughing]
[gentle music playing]
At first glance, I would have perhaps
liked a little glaze on.
-Did you glaze them at all?
-I forgot.
[Prue] 'Cause that's… This means
they're a little dull to look at.
-They could be sort of shiny.
-I know.
The size of them are good.
The balls look a nice size.
The red dough is red bean curd,
and the green is like an Asian pesto,
and the other one with sesame seeds.
-Is there a little chili in there?
-Little bit.
It needs more salt.
The sesame one
has very little flavour to it.
[Prue] It's the same with this.
A little more salt
would bring out the flavour.
[Paul] Mm.
The balls actually are baked all right.
Probably need a little bit more proving
just to open them up a bit.
I'm just not getting
a huge amount of flavour in there.
Oh, okay.
[gentle music playing]
So my monkey bread was going to be
onion-flavoured with some yeast extract.
When you say "was",
you're talking in the past tense.
I didn't get pretty much any rise on it.
Obviously, it's sort of
trying to grow and it can't,
so basically, it's sort of fallen apart.
-[Prue] That's…
-[Aaron] I know.
[Paul] Oh, wow! It's like raw.
[Prue] Doesn't look
as if it's been in the oven.
-[Paul] No, it doesn't, does it?
-It's literally like dough.
[gentle music playing]
-Has a good flavour.
-[Paul] Has a great flavour.
But the texture is so awful
that you couldn't eat it.
-It's a shame, yeah.
-Bad luck.
-Thank you.
-I mean, thank you for your kind words.
[laughs] Cheers, guys.
[mouthing]
I mean, I think that their words
were a lot kinder than my bake deserved,
if I'm honest.
But it's just piled on the pressure
to try and do better
in the other challenges,
which I didn't really want today.
I think I was as close to a handshake
as I may ever be, so I'll take that.
He said the word "superb".
You don't hear "superb" a lot.
So I'm happy with that.
I am little bit disappointed
about the flavour bit.
I should put a bit more salt.
I'm not looking forward
to Technical challenge.
I will be at the bottom again.
It's not my thing.
[bird squawking]
[Noel] For the bakers'
next Bread Week challenge,
they have no idea
what they'll be asked to make.
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your Technical challenge.
And today your Technical challenge
has been set for you
by the chairman of the board.
And when I say board, I mean breadboard,
it's Paul Hollywood.
Paul, have you got any advice
for our bakers?
You know they idolise you.
[Paul] This is all about the planning.
Well, the planning and the timings.
Get those right, you'll be fine.
Now, as ever, your Technical challenge
will be judged blind.
So we're gonna have to ask these two punks
to leave the tent.
[all laughing]
[Alison] See you later.
Okay, for your Technical challenge today,
Paul Hollywood would love you
to make his take
on that fast food classic,
the glazed ring doughnut.
He'd like you to make
twelve ring-shaped doughnuts.
All should be covered
in a classic vanilla glaze,
and six of them should be dipped
in a strawberry icing.
There's a lot riding on this, kids,
so doughnut mess this up.
[Alison laughs]
You got two hours, 45 minutes.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
[Noel in high pitch] Bake!
Oh! [groans]
Feeling incredibly daunted
about deep frying.
Well, who has a machine like that at home?
-[Jessika] Do you?
-No, I do not.
I wouldn't make doughnuts.
I'd be making fish and chips.
-Ooh.
-Look at that.
I've never made doughnuts before.
I make doughnuts many times.
Should be okay.
Paul, I know you like a doughnut.
I'll be honest with you.
Doughnuts are my guilty pleasure.
For a main course,
I'd have a load of hot dogs,
and then for dessert,
have a load of doughnuts.
That would be my ideal meal.
They look easy, but actually, it isn't.
They need to use as much time as possible
on the proving.
Notice that on every one of these
you have a white band
that runs round the middle.
If they don't have the white band,
it hasn't been proved enough.
The chances are it's gonna be quite dense.
Well, have you told them
how long to prove for?
No, they don't need to be told that.
I would have thought one of the problems
is getting that ring.
[Paul] They've got several
little cutters actually,
so the chances are
they may choose something too small.
-And it'll close up.
-And that hole will just disappear.
Okay, Prue, choose your doughnut.
I'm gonna go for a plain one.
-I'm gonna have this, the pink one.
-Oh, okay.
Oh, yes.
You can see how soft it is inside.
Oh, my God. I am covered in icing.
Finger lickin' good.
[gentle music playing]
Recipe is not very detailed,
so the first note is,
"Make the dough and leave to prove".
"Self-raising
and strong white flour together."
[Alison] Adding self-raising flour
and yeast
should ensure a light, fluffy texture…
I imagine the self-raising flour
will give it extra lift.
…if they follow
one of Paul's instructions very carefully.
I need to warm… Warm the milk up first.
So then it should activate the yeast
and it goes frothy.
If you make it too hot,
it kills the yeast.
I try to put the hot milk and the yeast…
but it's not rising.
I'm a bit worried, I still worry.
[Alison] How's my Aaron?
Does it put you off
when you have a bad Signature?
That's in the past anyway now.
We've moved into the future.
-Oh, I love your attitude.
-Yeah.
It's in the past. It's gone.
-Yeah. You look good.
-Thank you.
-You know what I mean?
-Oh, it's what I needed.
It's like a ego boost to keep me going.
-As long as you look good, babes.
-[laughs]
Who cares? Just look good.
-You always look good, babe.
-And you can smash anything.
Dough's out.
I'm trying do a bit of slap and fold.
[Aaron] I want it to look cute.
I want it to be ready.
I want it to be tasty.
It's blobbing.
It does look like it's alive.
It looks like it's an animal.
How are you feeling it's going in general?
[Pui Man] I just hope
I won't be at the bottom again.
You're right at the back,
you can see what everyone else is doing.
-I don't cheat.
-You never cheated at school?
-No. I never cheat.
-Not once?
Really? Did you do well at school?
-No. Never did well. [laughs]
-[laughs]
"Number three, prove."
I put this in the proving drawer
until it double in size.
I'm gonna prove it about half an hour,
see how it goes.
This is the face of somebody
who just wants to do well. [chuckles]
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Keep going, guys.
-Right. Let's make the glaze.
-"Six hundred grammes of icing sugar."
"Thirty coconut oil."
They haven't given you
an amount of whole milk,
so I don't think it's a lot.
If you get the glaze consistency wrong,
it'll be like really thick and gloopy
all over it.
Or there won't be any at all.
I essentially want the glaze
to be like a thin liquid
that will just coat the outside.
I doing it by eye.
[laughs] My eyes, like… [laughs]
Oh! The glaze is good. I'm done.
Thank you so much.
"Make the strawberry icing to coat
the tops of six of the glazed doughnuts."
Oh, that is strong.
I went for it. I went… [grunts]
About 20 drops.
I feel like it needs to be
really red as well.
This is where they're gonna go,
"Hmm, it looks a bit too red".
[Alison] With glazes and icings in hand,
the bakers can return to their dough.
Let's have a wee look.
[Alison] If they prove it for too long,
it could develop large air bubbles
and collapse when it's fried.
Obviously don't want to overprove.
[Alison] But if it's underproved,
their doughnuts will be dense.
Anyone else out?
I'm gonna do two more minutes.
[Toby] It's passing the test.
It's slowly springing back,
and it's not coming all the way,
so it seems like it should be proved.
[Jasmine] I need to get going.
[Pui Man] It's not rising.
Not much happening.
"Shape the dough into 12
approximately seven-centimetre
ring doughnuts."
[Noel] The judges will be expecting
a batch of identically-sized
perfect ring-shaped doughnuts.
Paul loves uniform things.
[Noel] But the bakers haven't been given
any directions on how to achieve that.
I don't know how to get my hole in.
I'm just gonna do it with this.
We'll get a neat hole.
Everyone wants a neat hole,
don't they? [laughs]
[Noel] It's quite big, that hole.
-Yeah, but remember that it expands.
-Okay.
So you'd think this was a big enough hole.
I'm gonna look over… [mumbles]
How big should a doughnut hole be?
I have no preference on hole size.
[laughs]
[Noel] But while everyone else
is shaping their rings…
[Jasmine] They look like doughnuts,
which is great.
…Pui Man is at a standstill.
My dough is not rising
as much as I thought.
And I am seeing everyone, like,
shaping their doughnut already.
I don't know, I may have killed the yeast.
Three, six, nine, twelve.
Anybody know what the bags are for?
A cape.
[Jasmine] Gonna bag my doughnuts.
I've never used one of these bags before,
but we got given it, so I'm gonna use it.
[Lesley] Put them back in to prove.
I leaving it for 30 minutes or so.
[Pui Man] I need to start shaping it.
I just hope I can do this in time.
Stay positive, stay positive.
[tense music playing]
Bakers, you've got one hour left.
Wondering how long
we need to prove it for.
[Alison] It's crucial that the doughnuts
get adequate proving time…
I'm just trying to give it
as long as I can.
Waiting for it.
…but the bakers also need to calculate
how long they'll need
to fry, cool, and decorate them.
Paul said about timing, planning. [sighs]
I need to work out timings,
'cause I have no idea
how long they take to fry.
Tom's reckoning 45 seconds.
[Iain] I don't trust Tom with a Technical.
I'd trust Toby with a Technical.
-Yeah, he's won twice, hasn't he?
-Yeah.
And he's the wee bread boy.
-So you know…
-[Noel] The wee bread boy.
-His moustache is made of bread.
-[laughs]
[Noel] I just said your moustache
was made of bread.
[laughs]
Put this in the proving drawer.
I should have enough time.
[suspenseful music playing]
Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
[exclaims]
I reckon that's probably done.
[Noel] While Pui Man is still waiting
for her second prove…
Dough is proving,
so there's nothing I can do.
…the other bakers can move on
to the next step.
Number four is, "Fry the doughnuts".
Let's do this, Noel. Let's do it.
[Noel] This is exciting.
She floats, which is a good sign.
I'm gonna do two at a time,
two minutes on each side.
-I reckon three at a time.
-Three at a time!
I'm gonna do four in a batch.
If I put too many in at one time,
it's gonna reduce
the temperature of the oil.
If you have it too low,
it will absorb too much oil,
and then it will become greasy
and unpleasant to eat.
[Pui Man] Oh, I need to
start to deep fry them.
Otherwise, I won't have time.
[Jasmine] I think that colour's good.
-[Noel] Like the back of Paul's hand.
-[laughs]
How does he get that colour?
You know the ice baths that everyone has?
-Paul has one of these.
-[laughs]
He can do eight minutes.
-Ooh.
-Absolutely.
-In his little Speedos. [laughs]
-[laughs]
Oh, gosh.
I deep fry about three minutes each side.
I just don't want them
to be doughy inside,
so they might be a little bit too brown.
[Jasmine] I'm feeling okay with them.
They look like doughnuts, which is great.
It seems like
they've got the doughnuts already.
I'm gonna glaze them now.
[Nataliia] Okay, let's do this.
[Alison] The judges are expecting
a thin, translucent glaze.
[Aaron] I do love a glazed ring.
[Jasmine] They feel good.
[Nadia] It's very messy.
[Tom] Whoa.
That was thicker than I thought.
[Lesley] I don't know
whether they're a bit overdone.
-[Noel] Nice onion rings.
-They're not onion rings!
[laughs]
-Oh, they look gorgeous.
-No, they're not.
-I know they're not. I know.
-Are you sure? How do you know?
Because I make doughnut
all the time at home.
-I know…
-He's gonna have a problem with them.
-Yes.
-[Alison] Keep going.
-Keep going until finish.
-Keep going, sweetheart.
[Pui Man] Ah, this one too much icing.
-Be positive.
-I know. Be positive.
Be positive, darling.
[Alison] The bakers
have been asked to coat
six of their doughnuts
with strawberry icing.
They feel really crispy. [laughs]
This one too small. [sighs]
[Pui Man] I need to do six pink
and then I need to decorate them
in red and white.
"Paint red and white spiralling circles."
Spiralling.
[Jasmine] They said spiral.
How long do I have?
Bakers, this is it. One minute left.
One minute.
[Aaron] Oh, good God.
This is so stressful!
My hand's shaking.
[Pui Man] Oh, my God.
[tense music playing]
-[Nadia] Reckon I've nailed it.
-Bakers, your time is up.
Please come and bring
your beautiful doughnuts
and place them behind your photos.
-[Tom] Yours look great.
-No, underproved.
-What you worried about?
-I don't know what happened.
[gentle music playing]
[Noel] Paul and Prue are looking
for 12 golden brown, uniform,
beautifully decorated ring doughnuts.
That's a lot of doughnuts. [laughs]
-It is a lot of doughnuts
-Yes.
[Paul] Right.
Actually, for the first one,
they don't look too bad.
-The white line is good.
-They're the right colour, aren't they?
[Paul] Decoration's pretty good.
It's pretty even.
-The crumb looks good.
-[Prue] Hmm. Nice and light.
[Paul] It's nice on the mouth.
It's quite soft. Good.
-[Prue] Good.
-[Paul] Okay.
It hasn't proved enough.
You see there's no white line.
There is much too much icing on that.
Look at that.
It's an acceptable doughnut.
-[Paul] Hmm.
-[Prue] But it's a bit heavier. Yeah.
[Paul] These are massively underproved
and very, very dark.
Let's have a look inside.
They took a bit of a saw.
You see how dense that is.
[Prue] Overfried as well.
[Paul] The flavours are good,
but the texture's all wrong.
And they're uneven.
Some of them are much smaller than others.
[Paul] Yeah, these don't look too bad.
[Prue] Well, this one doesn't look
as if it's iced at all.
The icing has been so liquid,
it's just disappeared.
Mm, soft.
-The crumb is nice.
-Mm.
The texture's okay. Nice shape.
I mean, look at the inconsistencies.
[Prue] This is a tiny little one.
[Paul] Look how dark it is.
That actually tastes burnt as well.
-It's very greasy, look.
-[Paul] Mm.
Now, I quite like these.
The icing on this isn't particularly neat.
They match.
-[Paul] True.
-[Prue] Quite original.
And it's thinly glazed,
which is what I like.
-[Paul] Absolutely. White line's there.
-[Prue] They've got the white line.
This is quite light inside as well.
-Mm, tastes good.
-It's delicious.
These are so uneven.
I mean, some of them look well risen
and some of them look tiny.
Actually, it's not as tight
as I thought it would be.
No.
Well, that's one of the bigger ones.
-[Prue] Mm.
-[Paul] Yeah.
It's as if they've been done
in two batches.
Yeah. Very inconsistent.
[chuckles] Look,
someone's tried to be clever.
[Prue] Oh. Well, why not?
I think that looks really good.
It's not quite the decoration
we told you to do, but it's lovely.
[Paul] The lines are good, the consistency
and the colour is pretty decent.
-Gosh, that's very big bubbles in there.
-[Paul] Mm.
Yeah, it's quite open.
It's been well mixed.
Overall, these don't look too bad.
The shaping has created a bit of an issue.
It needed to be slightly thicker
on the glaze on this runoff.
[Prue] This dough is nice and spongy.
It is. It tastes okay.
[Prue] Just a little bit uneven.
-The icing is pretty terrible.
-Look.
Yeah, the icing on this is a bit thin.
And then, ironically,
when you move on to the last one,
this is just way, way too thick,
and they're all inconsistent as well.
It's a bit of a mess.
-They're quite big.
-[Prue] Yeah, they're nicely risen.
The bigger ones are really good doughnuts.
Yeah.
[Noel] Paul and Prue
will now rank the doughnuts
from least to most successful.
In tenth place, we have this one.
-[chuckles] Pui Man.
-Okay.
These are overfried and underproved.
In ninth spot, we have these.
Who are these little beauties?
-Lesley…
-I wouldn't go that far.
Way, way overfried.
And there's just no consistency
in the shape as well.
[Noel] Nataliia is eighth,
Jessika is seventh,
Iain is sixth, Tom fifth,
Toby comes fourth, and Aaron is third.
And then in second place we have this one.
Nadia, they're nicely iced.
They're pretty well risen.
-Excellent.
-Thank you.
Which means in first place, Jasmine.
[cheerful music playing]
Icing was very good.
You had a lovely texture inside.
They were nice doughnuts. Well done.
[screams excitedly]
Well, that just happened.
And it's Bread Week, which I feel is like…
[laughing] I feel a little bit better
after the disaster that was this morning.
[Pui Man gasps] Oh, well.
Have some beer later. [laughing]
Forget about it and crack on tomorrow.
[Alison] Just one final challenge
before the judges decide
who will be Bread Week's Star Baker
and who will be leaving the competition.
Well, here we have it.
Bread Week, dread week.
Let's talk about some of the bakers.
Let's look at Aaron.
Aaron had a bit of a disaster
in the Sig, didn't he?
[Paul] Yeah, he did.
But he didn't do too bad in the Tech.
-[Noel] No.
-[Paul] But then you have Pui Man.
I don't think Pui Man
had enough salt in her Signature.
It didn't really create a lot of flavour.
[Prue] Pui Man did not have
a good day, really.
You have to mention Nataliia as well.
Because Nataliia's Signature
was meant to be a savoury bake.
But it was so sweet.
Iain smashed it yesterday.
Thing is about Iain,
he did really well in the Signature
and then he was sixth in Technical,
so he has slipped down a bit.
[Alison] Yeah.
There is one person, I thought,
doing extremely well, I think is Jasmine.
She won the Technical
and did well in the Signature as well.
-Nadia too.
-[Paul] She's doing okay.
If she has a good day today,
she could be up there.
It seems like there's a lot to play for
in the Showstopper.
Oh, definitely.
I'd like to see you two in tracksuits
with whistles giving team talks.
I'd pay to see that, actually.
I'm in.
[laughing]
[suspenseful music playing]
Bakers, welcome
to your Showstopper challenge.
Today, the judges would love you
to make a fantastic
celebratory sweet bread
with at least three tiers.
Your Showstopper should be made
with an enriched bread dough.
And should be designed to represent
a celebration that has meaning for you.
You have five hours
to celebrate sweet bread.
[Noel] On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
[uplifting music playing]
I can't have a bad day today. [laughs]
I just want to do well.
[exhales deeply] Calm down. Calm down.
[Prue] Today's Showstopper challenge
is an enriched bread, three tiers of it,
made into a sort of
celebratory Showstopper.
Like a tiered wedding cake,
but made out of bread.
For me, what I want to see is
beautifully flavoured
and well-baked loaves
that really show off the bakers' skills.
[Toby] Unbelievable stance.
-Unbelievable.
-[Aaron chuckles]
Power.
The introduction of flavours
is going to be quite tricky
because the addition
of all the ingredients
into the dough can slow things up.
Add too much fruit, for instance,
then again, that slows the yeast up.
You've got to get your timings right,
your proving right, your baking right.
Get the consistency right.
If it isn't, there's gonna be trouble.
Morning, Aaron.
-Morning.
-Good morning, Aaron.
Right, Aaron, tell us
all about your sweet bread.
So I'm doing a celebration of life
sweet bread
for two of my friends
who passed away a few years ago.
Aliesha and Fidel.
My friends have always been supportive
of me getting on to Bake Off,
so it just felt fitting.
And I'm doing four couronnes stacked,
and then down one side
there will be some flowers for Fidel,
roses for Aliesha.
-Sounds like a fitting tribute.
-Thank you.
[Noel] Aaron's ambitious
French couronne bread
will be festooned
with a cascade of flowers
and filled with pistachio marzipan,
cherries and apricots.
Couronne is such a beautiful bread
made right.
Yeah, I really tried to finesse
this one for you guys. [laughs]
Well, you've got five hours.
Yeah, and I'm making good time
'cause they bake quite fast as well,
'cause there's a hole in the middle.
-[Noel] Good luck.
-Thanks, guys.
[Alison] Also going for a classic
French celebration bread is Nadia.
I am making a wedding cake, a French one.
It's beautiful. It's a nice brioche dough
with a nice
raspberry crème pâtissière inside.
It's really pretty.
I just love weddings.
I've never been married,
but I love weddings.
[Alison] Nadia's sweet bread tower
will be decorated
with dozens of hand-piped
buttercream blooms,
fit for the wedding of her dreams.
We're going to a wedding.
Is it your wedding?
Well, I've been waiting a very long time.
-Have you got a boyfriend?
-Yeah.
-Not put a ring on it yet?
-No.
-What's his name?
-Daniel.
What are you playing at, Daniel?
What are you playing at?
Remember, there's no ring on it,
anyone could take her.
Let me chuck this in the proving drawer.
[Noel] While the bakers wait
for their dough to increase in size…
So prove for an hour.
…they can focus on their fillings.
[Nadia] This is my creme pat
with loads of fresh raspberries.
[Pui Man] This is glazed cherry.
[Alison] But adding ingredients
with more moisture…
[Lesley] Just straining off the liquid
so they're not too wet
going into the dough.
…can run the risk of wet and sticky dough
that won't rise properly.
-How are you doing, Iain?
-I'm okay.
-What's going on?
-So this is gonna be celebrating Samhain,
-which is the Irish precursor…
-Samhain?
Yeah, it's the Irish precursor
to Halloween.
-Oh, I love this.
-Yeah.
-Like jack-o'-lanterns and stuff.
So they used to have these little turnips
that they would carve
terrifying faces into.
-Really?
-Yes. Horrifying.
So is yours going to be horrifying?
-Hopefully, yeah.
-Okay.
I want to scare the judges a wee bit.
[Alison] Iain's spooky sweet breads
will be flavoured with apple and cinnamon
and decorated with edible paint
and dead dough decorations,
celebrating his girlfriend Dervla's
favourite time of year.
My girlfriend, erm,
she says that she looks like you
-and, erm, wants you to know that.
-[Noel chuckles]
I mean, it's scarily close.
-It is scarily close.
-[laughing] I feel sorry for you.
So she looks like
a sort of dug up zombie Elvis?
Yeah, that was what attracted me
to her in the first place.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah. All right.
I've pulled.
[laughs]
[Noel] Also dedicating his bread
to someone special is Tom.
My boyfriend,
his favourite time of the year is autumn,
so mine is just all about
that changing time of the year
when all the leaves fall off the tree.
How are you doing that in bread?
I've got a three-tiered
cinnamon bun tower,
and then I'm gonna have
some chocolate decorations
because it's Bread Week,
so why not decorate out of chocolate?
[Noel] Tom's sculpted chocolate tree
will shower autumn leaves
onto the orange cream cheese icing
that will cover his orange,
cinnamon and pecan nut rolls.
Let's hope it tastes as good as it sounds.
I don't know if I have the substance
to back it up, but let's see.
-We'll find out.
-[chuckles nervously] Let's see.
I think I'm gonna have to get my dough
out of the proving drawer.
Whatever it looks like,
it's got to come out.
Pretty big.
[Toby] I don't know if it's risen
as much as I would like it to,
but I haven't got time to mess around now,
so I just have to get on with it.
[Alison] The bakers now face a race
to get their bread filled and shaped
before it proves for a second time.
[Iain] There's gonna be some apple
and cinnamon burrowed into the loaf.
So hopefully,
they don't leak into the dough.
[Aaron] So this is my fruit filling.
It's just the apricots,
the lemon and the sour cherries.
[Jasmine] So this is
the cinnamon cardamom butter.
I'm actually gonna fold it.
Almost like making laminated pastry
when you put butter inside.
-Morning, Jasmine.
-Morning. Hello.
Right, Jasmine, tell us all about
your sweet bread. What are you doing?
So I'm gonna do
a Swedish cinnamon and cardamom
-midsummer celebration bread.
-Lovely.
[Alison] Jasmine's plaited
kanelbullar loaves
will be made from sweet cardamom dough,
filled with cinnamon, sugar and butter
and decorated with delicate
Scandi-style icing.
Ironic that I'm plaiting
when I have no hair to plait myself.
I had my own hair completely
until I was like 12,
and the doctors didn't really know why…
Like, no one really knows
what causes alopecia,
or there was nothing that triggered it.
I just randomly started losing my hair.
So it literally wasn't until,
yeah, a couple of years ago
when I stopped wearing my wigs.
And it was really hard at the start,
going outside, without wearing a wig
and just looking different.
But I feel like
I'm really getting to the point
where I genuinely am starting to enjoy,
like, not having hair and being different.
[Noel] The bakers need to carefully
shape their filled doughs
to create the perfectly formed
sweet breads
that Paul and Prue are expecting.
[Noel] But he likes things very neat.
If things are chaotic,
I can see him sweating.
He doesn't like it.
How does he cope with you?
-[laughs]
-Yeah, he doesn't even know what I am.
[both laugh]
[Alison] And while most of the bakers
are shaping the dough
before it returns to the proving drawer,
Jessika is relying on the second prove
to shape her loaves.
[Jessika] So the string around it,
essentially what I'm doing is
I'm trying to make each tier
look like a pumpkin.
-So as it proves…
-…it will stretch into the string.
-That's sick.
[Alison] Jessika's pumpkins
will be sandwiched with apricot conserve
and orange-infused crème pâtissière,
decorated with crops
and rain dancing figures
to celebrate her time working in Uganda.
I would work in communities
that mainly focussed on agriculture,
and they experienced a lot of drought.
So when the rain came,
the women and children would leave
their houses and dance in the rain
to celebrate the coming of the rains
and the prosperity of the ground
to hopefully grow their crops.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
You've got two and a half hours left.
[Noel] The second prove
is the bakers' last chance
to get their dough ready for baking…
[Pui Man] Hopefully, will puff up.
…producing a light and airy bread,
and open crumb structure
that the judges are looking for.
[Toby] So this is the bread
that stole Christmas.
I can't sacrifice that second prove today
'cause Paul said
it was slightly underproved
on the second one yesterday.
Let's hope Christmas comes early
for me this week.
[Noel] Toby's hoping
he can redeem himself today
with his festive stollen breads,
filled with mixed fruit,
spices and marzipan,
celebrating his favourite time of year.
I absolutely love Christmas.
I always have.
We stockpile stollen every year.
That's why I wanted to go
for stollen-inspired bread,
and it tastes great.
Can't lose, surely.
-Nataliia. Morning.
-Hello.
-[Prue] Hello, Nataliia.
-Morning.
Nataliia, tell us about
your celebration bread.
So, today, I'm gonna make my Korovai.
It's Ukrainian wedding cake,
which is a recipe
of my grand, grandmother.
So I hope it works today.
Paul, don't look at me like that. [laughs]
I'm so scared of you.
How can I have a go at your grandmother?
[both laugh]
[Noel] Nataliia's traditional
Korovai wedding bread
will be made from an enriched dough,
packed with butter
and flavoured with orange,
cinnamon, and rum,
all from a family recipe
passed down to her from her mum.
She a good baker?
Good baker,
but I think she's better with cooking.
-And is she here, or in the Ukraine?
-Here.
-Does she watch the show?
-Yeah.
-Hello, Nataliia's mum.
-Hi, Mum. [laughs] Hello.
She said you were a better cook
than a baker.
-No. [laughs] I never said.
-[laughs]
You know, everything you say,
they're filming.
-She's gonna find out.
-[laughs]
[Noel] But Nataliia's family recipe
has competition.
So I'm making a Korovai-style sweet bread.
-Ooh. That's controversial.
-Three tiers.
-Is it?
-You know Nataliia is making one.
-She is Ukrainian.
-Yeah, I know. No pressure.
[Alison] Lesley's hoping
her Korovai sweet bread,
enriched with rum-soaked raisins,
blood oranges and cinnamon
will hold its own,
and she's decorating it with flowers
for her granddaughter.
My little granddaughter, Mabel,
she's coming up for two
and she loves flowers.
And on her first birthday,
we had a daisy theme,
so a little nod to her.
[Alison] Also saying it with flowers
is Pui Man.
-I bought my house.
-Yeah.
-There's a rose tree outside my house.
-Stunning.
Erm, but I cut that off.
Why? You cut the roses off?
-Yeah, I took the whole plant off.
-Oh, my gosh.
-It's because for Chinese Feng Shui.
-Huh?
Roses are not good for your love life.
No? Why didn't you, like,
plant it round the back?
-Then my boyfriend at the time…
-Yeah. Yeah.
…bought me a plant,
a rose plant,
and plant it at the back garden.
Now we got married.
-[chuckles]
-So, think the love curse broken.
[Alison] Pui Man's tribute
to her husband, Paul,
will see three layers
of plaited milk bread
filled with a coconut paste
and glacé cherries,
adorned with roses
sculpted from bread dough.
How do you make your roses then?
I use the circle cutter.
-[Paul] You do.
-Yeah.
-You line them all up and roll it up.
-Yes.
Impressive.
I tried it at home.
-It went well most of the time.
-Okay.
So, hopefully, this will go well.
So second prove's done.
First behemoth. She's going in.
Ooh. [inhales deeply] Wish me well.
-[Noel] As their dough hits the heat…
-[Jessika] Going in.
…the bakers can get to work
on making their decorations
that will elevate
their celebratory sweet breads
to showstopping levels.
[Tom] I'm making my lovely chocolate tree.
Roses are for Aliesha,
and the sunflowers are for Fidel.
These are gonna be on top,
so I want them to look nice.
[Lesley] The bread's quite dark,
so the daisies really add
a bit of colour to it.
My roses look quite good. Yeah.
[Jessika] Gonna make some rain clouds.
These are the turnip lanterns.
They're terrifying.
What the hell is that?
-Wha… [laughs] Babes.
-I've done some more.
That's the most disgusting thing
I've ever… Oh!
That's a worse one.
[Alison] What is that?
-It's gonna be a tree eventually.
-It really doesn't look like a tree, Tom.
[Alison] It looks like a big log.
Wait. Wait and trust me.
-[laughs]
-Smells nice though.
[laughs] Thank goodness.
[Alison laughs]
[gentle music playing]
[Noel] What's this?
It's like a little octopus.
[Jasmine] I've got some leftover flowers.
We could maybe catapult it somewhere.
-Who should we take out?
-No, let's…
-Who looks like they're doing well?
-Tom.
[Jasmine] Go for the head.
I'll go for the feet.
One, two, three.
Oh, my gosh! Jesus. [laughs]
-[Tom] Blimey.
-We flicked baby octopus at you.
Sorry. I'm so deep in the focus
trying to make this not look like a poo.
-Oh, good. These two are done.
-[oven beeping]
[Alison] As the sweet breads
come out the oven…
Fab.
…it's the moment of truth
for the bakers' Showstoppers.
Definitely a little over.
It's not as pretty as I wanted it,
but it's fine.
I'm gonna cover it with daisies. [laughs]
It's a good bake.
I don't think it's raw. [laughs]
The flavours, I know, are good.
So I'm actually just chuffed I'm on time.
[Alison] But not everyone is happy.
[Toby] Please be done.
That's gotta go back in.
[Toby] That is definitely not done.
[exhales] Still not done.
Bakers, you have one hour left.
I need 45 minutes to decorate,
so that's fine.
As long as they're out
in the next 10 minutes and start to cool.
Other people's breads
are looking really good.
This is kind of stressful.
[Noel] Whilst Toby and Iain
face an anxious wait…
Come on.
…the other bakers
must get their breads cooled…
[Jessika] It's hot.
It's hot, it's hot, it's hot.
…and decorative elements finessed…
[Jasmine] I'm shaking a bit.
…before assembly can begin.
These are just the little flowers
that are going round the edges.
Got some bling for these roses,
because I live in Essex.
[laughs]
[Aaron] I just want to get the roses done.
So I've got an equal amount of roses
to sunflowers.
Okay, just gonna glaze this super quickly.
[Nataliia] I've made my old lace
from milk with cornflour and gelatin.
[gasps] Yay, so beautiful.
I'm a little bit worried.
I desperately just want it to be done, out
and looking all right,
'cause at the moment,
it's not even gonna be done,
let alone decorated.
So it's eating into decoration time.
Bakers, you've got half an hour left.
Oh!
Where am I next? Oh, here.
[Jessika] Keep going, come on, come on.
[Alison] As most of the bakers
start to assemble their Showstoppers…
They are still very hot,
but I have to start decoration,
otherwise, I won't have enough time.
That's out.
…Iain and Toby…
[Toby] That's a big unit, that is.
…have no other option
but to get their breads out of the oven.
Some colour on that one.
[Toby] Ideally, these will cool quickly.
But see, underproved.
You can see 'cause it's cracked there.
Paul's gonna have a field day on that,
isn't he?
Oh, I've just gone over the top
with the red.
[laughs] It's like there's been a murder.
What's going on? It's everywhere.
[Noel] I feel like
this is a handshake already.
-[Alison] Yeah.
-[Nadia] No one's gonna shake this hand.
[Noel laughs]
[voice cracks] Bakers, you have…
-Got consumption.
-You can do it. Noel.
You have ten minutes left.
Who have you become?
-Joan Rivers.
-[both laugh]
Oh, please don't squash.
Oh, please.
[Iain] Just gotta do this really quick.
[Toby] Bread Week would be
the worst week to start crumbling.
Come on. Ooh.
[Aaron] I'm actually really happy with it.
[Toby] Oh, God, that looks rough.
[Iain] This is gonna be terrible.
This is gonna be terrible.
Oh, sugar.
I haven't got enough royal icing.
[Iain] It's meant to be a glaze
that will harden like a toffee apple,
but that looks quite dark.
I want to have it,
but it's not gonna be good if it's burnt.
[Jessika] How long we got left, sorry?
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Oh, God.
[Iain] It's so annoying.
This went so well in practice as well.
-[Toby] Oh, stick on.
-[Nadia] Lovely.
[Aaron] Even if they say
it tastes like trash,
at least I know it looked good.
[laughs]
Now for this bit. Don't tell anyone.
-Bakers, your time is up.
-[Tom] We're done.
Please step away from your Showstoppers.
Oh, I feel rough.
I feel rough about that.
Is that good enough?
I don't know.
[Iain] Oh, my God.
[suspenseful music playing]
[Noel] The celebration sweet breads
now face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
Jasmine, will you please bring up
your Showstopper?
[gentle music playing]
[Prue] It's beautiful.
It's really very delicate.
I do like the decoration,
I like the icing.
The icing consistency is spot on as well.
It's very pretty.
So it's got cinnamon and cardamom in it.
The cardamom level
and the cinnamon level are very nice,
and, actually,
the dough's baked beautifully.
You've got a good amount of swirls
in there.
So that is very good.
And also,
I think it looks incredibly pretty
and it tastes fantastic.
[Paul] Mm. Well done, Jasmine.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] A bit wonky,
but I think it looks very good.
[Prue] Let's see what it's like inside.
It has marzipan inside,
and the bread is enriched
with butter, eggs, apple juice and milk.
The bread It's not quite done.
It's quite doughy.
That is such a pity,
because I think that is
the best-tasting stollen I've ever had.
Ah.
[gentle music playing]
[Prue] Well, I think it's really dramatic,
very neatly done.
[Paul] I do like the bold colour
on the outside.
I think it looks stunning.
This is orange cinnamon
and pecan cinnamon rolls.
Mm, I love the crunchy filling,
and the cream cheese icing is lovely.
Love it.
What I do like is the bread itself.
It's light, but then the fillings
just really pack a punch.
It's beautiful, yeah.
-Well done, Tom, excellent.
-Thank you so much, guys.
[Prue] I like the little figures,
the colours are great.
It's a little bit clumsy,
but the bake is lovely.
[Paul] Let's have a look
and see what it's like inside.
It's a Japanese milk bread
filled with a creme pat,
infused with some orange zest
and some cardamom.
And there's an apricot conserve.
All the flavour comes from the creme pat.
-Yeah.
-You want something more.
Maybe fruit inside the bread
would've been nice as well.
-You could've done more with the bread.
-Sure.
[dramatic music playing]
I love the bake on it. I love the shine.
It really looks so appetising.
So this is a orange
and rum-soaked raisin sweet bread
in a Korovai style.
The texture's absolutely lovely.
It's springy, nicely baked.
I think you've done a great job.
It looks good, it's baked well,
great flavour, texture's good.
-Well done, Lesley. Thanks.
-Thank you.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] It's highly decorated.
[Prue] It's a little bit clumsy.
You've done the lace nicely,
but it's got a few joins.
I added orange zest, rum, vanilla extract,
and a bit of love. [chuckles]
[all laughing]
[Paul] Your spice levels
in the cake are good.
However…
-the dough itself is very claggy.
-[Nataliia] Mm-hmm.
[Paul] It needed much more proving.
I think there's some
really good things about it,
and I love the flavour.
There's just not quite enough finesse.
Thank you.
[gentle music playing]
[Paul] I like it. I really like it.
-I like the decoration.
-There's a lot of work in this.
I love the way you've done the roses.
They're perfect.
It just looks lovely.
So let's see how it tastes.
Inside, I have got
a white chocolate creme pat,
I've got a crème mousseline in the middle,
and I have also got
fresh raspberries inside.
That won't come off your fingers,
by the way.
Or your mouth. All right, Dracula?
[all laughing]
The texture is perfect.
You'd almost think it was a cake.
[Paul] It's very cake-like,
but it's light.
That's lovely. Well done.
[Noel] Show us your tongue.
[all laughing]
Sorry, guys.
[dramatic music playing]
[Prue] It looks absolutely lovely.
The coconut and sugar is glittery,
so it shimmers.
[Paul] I think the roses
have worked out well.
The pipe work's
a little bit all over the place.
Inside, I fill with coconut paste
and glacé cherries.
Really nice and powerful coconut flavour.
And I like the cherries.
Glacé cherries wouldn't be one
I would choose normally,
-but actually, the glacé cherries…
-I think it's lovely.
-…work really nice with this.
-Okay.
And I think the bread is baked
quite nicely as well. I quite like that.
-I think you've managed to achieve…
-Oh, thank you.
…something that has surprised me,
which is quite unusual.
-Well done. Thanks.
-Oh, thank you.
[dramatic music playing]
[Prue] It doesn't make you want to eat it.
[Paul] No, it doesn't.
There's certainly a Halloween feel to it.
-Samhain.
-[Iain] Yeah. Yeah.
So it is a sort of winter,
autumny-spiced, erm, sweet bread
with a cinnamon and apple swirl filling.
It's underbaked, sadly.
-Is it?
-[Paul] It's certainly underproved.
It's really claggy.
You cannot put apple in a bread like this
because apple will leak moisture
into a dough as it's trying to prove,
which will make it quite gloopy as well.
Just needed more punch.
[Paul] Thank you, Iain.
[dramatic music playing]
[Prue] You know,
I think it looks absolutely astonishing.
I actually love the look of this.
I love the couronne
because it's exposing what's inside.
And that's how it should look.
But let's have a look and see, shall we?
The bread is a couronne with pistachio,
marzipan, cherries, apricots,
and there is a light rose icing
on there as well.
Yes, Aaron.
-[chuckles softly]
-That's beautiful.
The pistachio, marzipan, the fruit level.
It's really tasty.
I think you've done
a decent job with that,
and the flavours you've chosen
have worked really well on this.
I think that's pretty faultless.
What a great tribute.
-Thank you, thank you.
-[Paul] Well done.
-[Alison] Yeah! [laughing]
-[Noel laughing]
-[Aaron laughing]
-[Alison] Well done.
-I told you I could bake bread. [laughing]
-[kisses]
-[Noel exclaims]
-Thank you.
I would have to say
I think that was probably
one of the most beautiful things
I've ever actually made.
Happy that I did well today.
But, equally…
[laughs] my Signature was so poor.
So there's always a possibility
we could go home.
I think that was the worst feedback
that anyone has gotten so far.
They didn't like flavour,
they didn't like the bake,
they didn't like anything.
I, 100%, think I'm going home.
They seemed to really like it.
So, which is great. [laughing]
Yeah, I'm proud, I'm happy.
But I'm also aware that there's a lot
of other amazing bakes in there.
[gentle music playing]
That was a wild ride, wasn't it?
What a Showstopper.
I was surprised about Iain's.
Let himself down a little bit on that one.
I didn't think it looked
as bad as you two.
That was my perfect birthday cake.
-Yes, exactly. It's your style, darling.
-[laughing]
Okay, and who's in line
for going home then?
Going into the Showstopper, it was Pui Man
and Nataliia who were in trouble.
I thought Nataliia's Showstopper
was quite clumsy and not exciting.
-[Paul] Hmm. Yeah.
-It was okay.
But I did really like Pui Man's.
I thought,
"This is the comeback kid again".
She always saves herself
in the Showstopper.
Yeah, but in the Technical,
she's either been down at the bottom
or second from bottom
in the last three weeks.
Dare I say Iain? It's a tricky one.
So who's in line for Star Baker?
Jasmine, for sure.
-Jasmine's had a pretty solid week.
-[Alison] Yeah.
I think Tom's really
pushed himself up today.
That was a great Showstopper.
And Nadia, Signature she did well,
second in the Technical,
and I thought
her Showstopper was fantastic.
-So I think in line for Star Baker.
-And did you like your red lips?
-No, not particularly.
-[Noel laughing]
It's the first time
I've ever wanted to kiss ya.
-Well…
-That is such a lie.
-Every week you try something.
-[all laughing]
I've got security on my door.
[all laughing]
[tense music playing]
Well done, bakers.
You survived Bread Week.
Luckily, I've got the great job
of announcing
which person
will be this week's Star Baker.
And the Star Baker this week is…
[suspenseful music playing]
Jasmine.
[all clapping]
You really deserved that,
really deserve it.
You deserve that.
Unfortunately, I've got the horrible job
of letting a baker go this week.
So, the baker
leaving the tent this week is…
[suspenseful music playing]
Pui Man.
-[exhales deeply]
-[mouthing]
[gentle music playing]
-No. Oh, my God.
-[Pui Man groans]
Little bit disappointed,
but I wasn't doing well most of the time.
But I am part of the Bake Off family now,
so, it's not a bad thing.
Absolutely gutted.
Today has been, er… rough.
Today's been really rough.
[snickers]
[producer] Feel like you've dodged
a bullet?
I've dodged a nuke.
Yay, well done. It's so deserved.
[Jasmine] You know what is cool?
Bread Week.
I'm happy I got Star Baker for Bread Week.
That feels good.
The judges liked what I was doing.
It was a fun week.
I've learned a lot.
What's more to want?
Can't believe I've survived Bread Week,
to be honest.
Well done, Nadia.
Paul's just come up to me and said,
"Very well done this week."
"You've done amazing
and you're right up there".
So basically,
"You were good, but not that good".
[laughing]
I want you to be up there where
you're thinking, "Have I won Star Baker?"
-Not, "Am I going home?"
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Oh, my gosh.
Oh, I'm happy I'm coming back next week.
I see you next week. [laughs]
It's so crazy.
[closing theme music playing]